The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, so by this time,
most of you should have
had your meetings with
your masters.
How many of you had meetings
with your masters?
Who didn't yet?
AUDIENCE: Today.
PROFESSOR: Today?
And Friday.
Who hasn't scheduled
a meeting?
So are you talking to them,
and do you know--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, make sure you get
masters meetings scheduled
because this is a very
important part.
We are getting feedback
from the masters.
I think they are giving you guys
a lot of good advice, and
so make sure you schedule, you
go, you meet, get that result,
use that result.
It's very hard to arrange that
kind of a senior person
spending a lot of time
with only two of
you at a given time.
That's a really good ratio
to have, so take
advantage of that.
OK, so also, I think at this
point, most of the beta issues
for project one, we have been
probably worked with, and they
have some issues some people
looked at that they are
performance code.
They were not happy because
the thing is this.
You can always run everything
instantaneously if it doesn't
have to produce a
correct answer.
You can just return, and so part
of performance is also it
has to have some correctness.
So certain amount of correctness
has to be passed
before we can give
performer grade.
So some people have
this question.
Why are you giving me a
correctness grade because it
seemed to run?
But if you haven't done the
right checks and stuff like
that, then it's unfair for other
people because there's
no way people who do the correct
implementation can
match that performance
because we're using
that as upper bound.
So make sure you do that.
And another issue people had
was when you go to masters,
you're going to work with one
or two other students.
And in your group, you're
going to share all the
material with your group
member and nobody else.
But between the beta and final,
you get opportunity to
basically get input from your
masters, and also see what the
other people who are coming
to a project in your
discussion have done.
So it's OK for you to
see those code.
You can't take the code home.
You can't just say give me a
print-out, I am going to take
home and re-implement.
That doesn't count, but if you
see some clever things they
have done, it's all
here to learn.
Class is all the mostly
about learning.
However we have to grade you, so
it's not all about grading,
it's about learning.
So we are trying to get a
balance where we opportunity
for you to learn from
your peers.
So if you go look at other
people's code, if you find
something cool they
have done, learn.
And also if you [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
for you [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
say, look, I did
something cool.
It's a good learning experience
in there, so that's
one opportunity you have to talk
to other people on other
groups, to basically learn
something or find some
interesting tidbits of how
to get good performance.
And hopefully, you learn some
interesting things and able to
implement that in your final.
OK?
So today we are going to talk
about memory systems and
performance engineering.
So if you look at basic idea
of what memory systems, you
want to build a computer
that seemed to have
a really fast memory.
You don't want things
to be slow.
For example, a long time ago,
people build these computers
where memory's always slow,
everything [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
further away.
It doesn't help anybody.
The way we know how to do that
is to build small amount of
memory very close to
the processor.
You can't build a huge amount
of things all close to you.
That doesn't work, doesn't
scale like that.
And we made a cache just like
that, and you build larger and
larger memory [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
going down, and the illusion
is you want to give the illusion
of you have huge
amount of memory.
Everybody's very close to you.
OK, so it looks like you have
millions of friends, that you
talk to everybody, and
that doesn't happen.
But how do you give
that illusion?
And the way that you give that
illusion is when you use
normal programming practice,
when you normally using data,
people have found there
are two properties.
The first thing is called
temporal locality.
That means if I use some data
item, there's a good chance I
use that data item
again very soon.
There is something I haven't
used for a long time, probably
has a good chance I will
not use it for a
very, very long time.
So can I take advantage
of temporal locality?
So that mean some data will be
get for use a lot of time, in
a very quick [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
so those things should be very
near to you because you might.
Other one is spatial locality.
That means if I use some data
item, there's a good chance
you'll be using data items next
to that, closer to that.
So can we take advantage
of that?
So those two properties help you
help the compiler to fool
the system, fool everybody,
thinking that it has this huge
amount of memory very close to
you, but internally doesn't.
Unfortunately, since it's trying
to fool you, it doesn't
work all the time, and when it
doesn't work, it's good to
recognize and able to
fix those things.
So I showed this picture
sometime ago, too.
Memories in a big hierarchy.
L1, L2, in fact, we have L3
cache and a memory, disk,
tapes, it can go up and down.
And the key thing is when you go
here, you're starting from
registers, you have very
small amount of
things, very fast access.
Here, we have almost
infinite amount of
things, very slow access.
And the two reasons why this has
to be smart because first
of all, those things
are very expensive.
And second of course, you can't
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] too
much, and when you go down,
things get somewhat cheaper.
So that was one of the kind of
economic incentive here.
So I talked about cache issues,
and I'm going to go
through this again because we
are really going to dig deep
into these things.
So when you have a cache, that
means you have a small memory
close to you that's basically
shadowing something sitting
behind you.
So when you ask for the data in
the cache, there are many
reasons why it's not there.
First thing is cold miss.
What that means is you're asking
for something that you
have never asked before.
It's the first time you're
asking, so the data is
probably sitting way behind
in your memory where,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
in a disk.
We haven't even loaded
it in there.
And the first time you have to
get it, so that get pulled in,
and so this seems to be a place
where there's nothing
you can do.
But another part of locality is
a thing called prefetching.
These modern processors
have a crystal ball.
They carry most of the things
that branch prediction and
stuff is trying to predict
what you want to do.
You can do the same
thing in memory.
You can look at what
you have done.
And Intel has this huge amount
of circuitry that they don't
tell anybody what they do, but
they're trying to predict what
you might fetch next, what data
you might look for next.
And if it is working well,
something you had never, ever
looked before, it might deduce
that you might need it and go
get it for you.
So if that works, great.
So then there's thing called
capacity miss.
What that means is as I said,
I am trying to keep my best
friends, or the people I will
be working with a lot--
Oh, nice.
What's going on here?
Please start later.
OK.
--the people I'm going to work
a lot with, close to me.
The problem is I can have only
certain number of friends, and
if you have more than that,
I can't keep everybody.
So hopefully, your program is
going to use a lot what we
call the working set that
can fit in the cache.
And at that point, you get all
of those people, like I said,
get everybody into one room,
and the problem is if your
party spills over from
the room, then
there's a lot of issues.
But if everybody fits in the
room, things are very nice.
You can have a good interaction,
continuous
interaction, with them.
And what happens is, if not, the
worst case is the caches
have eviction policy, normally
is called least recently used.
That means if I don't have room
in the cache, I figure
out the cache line that I
haven't touched for longest,
and I get rid of that,
bring the next one.
So that's a good policy.
It fits in your locality
thing, but when
will did not work?
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
going to figure out when least
recently used will create a
really bad problem
in capacity.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
just one.
Say you're [INAUDIBLE] set,
and that set is, by one,
bigger than the [INAUDIBLE]
missing.
PROFESSOR: Very good.
So what you're going through,
you're going round some data
again and again, and that amount
of data is one bigger
than your cache line.
You are going to have
no locality because
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], and when you
go to, just before you use
that data, they said, oops, I
need to bring one more data.
I need to evict something, and
who am I going to evict?
The guy I'm going to use next
because it was the least
recently used thing.
So it goes, and then you go
there, and you bring that.
Who's it going to evict?
You're going to evict the
one I just brought.
You're going to evict the next
one that I am just about to
use and bring that one.
And you go use that, and then
to use the next one, you're
going evict the one you're
just about to use.
So by going and doing that, you
basically get no locality.
So that's a really bad
problem in here.
So another interesting thing is
called a conflict misses.
Conflict misses says normally,
when you have a cache--
so what we have is you have
this large storage, which
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
the memory, you're going to map
into smaller storage in
here, which is cache.
So one way to say is any of
this value line can be
anywhere here.
That's called fully
associative cache.
Implementing that is somewhat
complicated, so the other
extreme is called direct
map cache.
What that means is this segment,
the same size here,
can map into here, and then
the next segment also
can map into here.
That means if you get this cache
line here, it can be
only mapped into one
place in this here.
This cache line can only be
here, and also this cache line
can also only be here if
it is the same offset.
So that means for every cache
line, there's only one
location in the cache.
So here, what would be
really sad scenario?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I mean
I assume I have a
lot of these slots.
I read something here, and the
next time I read something
here, next time I read something
here, and I go round
and round this way.
I might be touching only very
few number of data items, but
they also mapping into one
cache line even though my
working set is very small
than the cache.
I still don't have
any cache usage
because I am having conflicts.
And then there are two other
misses when you're going to
multi-process.
We'll go through them
in later lectures.
One is called true sharing.
That means there are caches
private to each core, and what
happens is if one core uses some
data, you've have to get
the cache line there.
If the other core wants to use
that data, you have to bring
the cache line back there, and
the cache lines can ping-pong
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] that.
False sharing is even
a worst way.
So what happens is if the first
processor here touches
this value of the cache line,
second processor touches this
value of the cache line.
We're not sharing anything,
but unfortunately, the two
things I'm using sits next to
each other, so when I ride
this thing, I get the cache
line, he doesn't.
When he need to ride this
thing, he has to
get the cache line.
So I am seemingly using
independent data, but I am
bouncing cache line in between,
and if that happened,
that going to have a huge
big performance impact.
So these other things.
The last two, we'll get
to a little bit later.
So today I am going to start
with modeling how caches work
with a very simplistic cache.
So here's, assume, my cache.
I have 32 kilobytes in here.
This is a direct map cache.
That means that in my memory, 32
kilobyte chucks get mapped
to direct [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
This 32 kilobyte get
mapped here.
That 32 kilobyte get
And the cache line inside is 64
bytes, 64, and that means I
have basically
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
32 kilobyte in here.
OK?
So just remember this as we go
on doing this, we will use
this as a formula.
OK?
And we assume if you getting
the cache, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
single cycle, if you
miss 100 cycles.
OK, so it's nice numbers
to do that.
And so the first thing is we
have a reference like this.
OK?
You go from [i] equals 0 to
[i] less than very large
number, A[i].
I just go to accessing memory
like one after another after
another after another.
So you see how this is
going on in here?
So also I am accessing integers,
so that means four
bytes at a time in cache line.
So what happens here?
So I assume size of int is four,
so you're getting four
bytes in here.
So yeah, you're doing s reads
to A. I'm accessing
s elements in here.
And you have 16 elements
of a per cache line.
OK, you see why 16 if there?
Because I have 64 in here,
64 bytes in here.
Each time axises four bytes,
so I have 16 of integers in
cache line.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
bits or bytes?
PROFESSOR: Bytes.
Byte.
Did I say bits?
No, bytes.
So what happens is if it axises
the same element, 15 of
every 16 is in the cache because
when we are going one
after the first guy, cache miss,
I had to go bring it,
and the next 15, I have
brought to it.
It's in the cache.
So what should be my cost?
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
cost of memory access.
I am accessing s data, and
1/16th of that is a cache
miss, 15/16th is a cache hit.
So basically total
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
is a 15/16th of s is a cache
hit, and other 1/16th I have
100 times cycles I need because
it's a cache miss.
Everybody good so far?
OK, so what type of locality
do we have here?
First of all, do we
have locality?
Who thinks we have locality?
OK, lot of people thinks
we have locality.
What type?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Spatial locality
because what we are doing is
we are accessing the nearby
elements even though we are
not getting back any of the
data yet, so we get some
spacial locality axis here.
That's good, so this is our
very -- most simple
thing we can do.
So what kind of misses are we
going to have in the cache?
Cold misses.
I'm missing because I have never
seen that data before,
so it's a cold miss in here.
OK, so that's that.
Let's look at this one.
I'm accessing A[0]
s times.
OK?
What's the total access time?
How many cache misses
am I going to get?
One, so I basically have 100
time for the first cache miss,
and s minus 1 for the rest
basically it's a hit.
OK?
That's good, so what kind
of locality's this?
Spatial or temporal.
There's not too many choices.
Or none.
How many people think spatial?
How many people think
temporal?
How many people said there's
none locality?
OK, that's a lot of temporal.
OK, you want to get
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
That's temporal locality here
because you're accessing to
the same thing again and again
and again, same data.
So this is--
Oh, OK.
Want to restart, OK.
Wait a little.
So this is only time we
notice in a hurry.
Every time, I go to do
something, I get hourglass.
So what kind of misses
are we getting?
Trick question.
I got one cold miss, and
that's about it.
And the rest I don't
have any misses.
So if I have a miss,
it's a cold miss.
OK, so here I am doing something
interesting.
So what the heck is
in this list?
So I'm accessing A[i]
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
this 2 to the power number,
one shifted to the entire
miss, 2 to the power N. I
shifted between 4 and 13.
What this 13?
Why is 13?
Less than 13.
What's 2 the power of 13?
I think I got this right.
AUDIENCE: 8,192.
PROFESSOR: What's 2 to
the power of 13?
AUDIENCE: 8,192.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, 8K.
And I have 32K.
So 8K of 32 [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
8K of integers, which is each
as 4 bytes is how much?
32K.
So what this says is everything
I access should fit
into the cache.
I am accessing data like that.
I'm going back and accessing
data like that.
data like that, and it should
all fit into the cache.
Do you see what I do?
I access up to 2 to the power
of 18, and I go back and
access that again.
I'm just going back
and back because
of the model operation.
Everybody see what's going on?
So how many cache misses
should I have?
AUDIENCE: There are four
cache [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, how many cache
lines I would be accessing if
I am doing i1 2 to
the power N?
[i]
mod 2 to the power N.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So one miss
for each axis line
the first time around.
Afterward, it's only
in the cache.
So how many axis lines?
2 to the power N.
Is that right?
I think this is wrong.
Oh, yeah, this is right
because every axis--
So in the cache line,
how many--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: This is four.
So there are 16 entries here.
16 entries in here.
OK, only one of them basically
misses that, so that means if
2 to the power N axises--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You are doing 2 to
the power N axises before you
go back in here.
So what you're doing
is you are--
you make this many axises before
you go back again.
OK?
And how many axises assigned to
be in the same cache line?
You have 64 bytes
in the cache.
OK each axis is four.
16.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: 16.
So that's true [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but what I'm
saying is I might not access
the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
because if any small.
I only access a certain amount
of cache line, so I'm
accessing a part of the cache.
I might not go through the--
can everybody see this, how
this is working?
Because if I'm only accessing,
we'll say, accessing one, if
this is, we'll say, 2
to the power of 5.
OK, I am not going to access
the entire cache line.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
cache is I'm going to
go through the cache.
So this many cache lines
I'm accessing.
OK, and the first time I access
that, I get a cache
miss, and after that, it say
everything is in the cache.
Everybody's following me?
Or are we like lost in here?
How many people are lost?
OK, let's do this.
So what happens is if you have
a modular 2 to the power N.
What that means is I'm going
to keep accessing one to
somewhere 2 to the power N, and
the next one, I am going
back here again.
That's my axises, basically,
because it goes
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
accessing to the power of N.
I nicely said n is
between 4 and 13.
So n is 13 means the maximum
I can do is 8K.
8K increase.
8K increase equals 32K
kilobytes of memory.
So that means you don't
have any option of
overwriting the cache.
So you go to cache,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
You don't wrap around
in the cache.
Do you see that?
OK, you know wrap arounding is
so bad, that means all these
things is going to fit in the
cache, and then when you get
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], this is
going to be in the cache
because the data you access is
smaller than the entire cache.
OK, so what that means is only
the first line has to have
some cache misses.
So how many cache misses
you are going to have
in the first line?
Or any of the lines going to
have cache misses because the
first line still fit
in the cache.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
anything.
We don't need everything.
How many cache misses
have in here?
The interesting thing is because
these are four bytes,
we have a 64-byte cache line,
and each is four bytes.
So that means I can do 16 axises
every time I have a
cache miss.
OK, so up to here to here is 2
to the N. My cache misses I do
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
basically.
My cache misses is basically
this much.
Everything else is in the cache,
and after the first
line, everything else is
in the cache again,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] nicely,
got my working set
to fit in the cache.
I'm really happy.
Everybody see this?
How many people don't
see it now?
OK, good.
So let's move to something a
little bit more complicated.
What kind of locality
do we have?
AUDIENCE: Temporal
and spatial.
PROFESSOR: Good.
We have temporal and spatial.
You have spatial because every
time you go, you only get the
first line of the cache.
Rest is in the cache.
From that, I got a 16x
improvement because I have
temporal locality.
And since I only access when I
go back to the data, after
accessing this, since it's
already in the cache, I get
spatial locality because
of the 16.
16 things are in the cache,
I am going through that.
I get spatial locality.
I get temporal locality because
next time I access,
it's still in the cache.
I haven't taken anything
out of the cache.
OK, what kind of misses?
Should be cold misses again.
Cold misses because the first
time I [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
things.
I haven't seen that data.
After I get it, everything
is in the cache.
So now, here's interesting
case.
Now, I am doing 2 to the power
N, where N is great than 14.
Now, what happens?
Now, what happens in our picture
here is I am going--
So as you might cache
is somewhere here.
At this point, I fill
out the cache.
I still keep going, and minute
I access something
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
cache, what's going to happen?
So I went through accessing
34 kilobyte.
If I access the next
one, what happens?
OK, no, no, no shutting
down, please.
OK, what happened?
So I am accessing more than
I can fit into the cache.
Next time access, what's
going to happen?
Anyone want to take
a wild guess?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
before that.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
in there.
So what happens is then am
I ever going to have any
temporal locality?
No.
OK, so now, first access to
each line basically misses
forever because by the time
I get back to the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE],
it's not there.
So basically, it's gone
out of the cache.
So what that means is my total
access time is basically every
16th element, I am getting
cache miss forever.
So what that means, every 15th
of 16, I have a hit.
So what I have is 15 out of
16, I have a cache hit.
1/16th of the time, I have
a cache miss forever.
So what kind of locality
do I have now?
I have spatial locality.
I don't have any temporal
locality.
I don't ever go back to
something in the cache again.
So what I have is spatial
locality, so what type of
misses now do I have?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Cold, right.
AUDIENCE: Is it like
shared misses?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's not shared.
When you fill out the cache,
you go back to
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
You fill the cache.
So what type of miss is that?
AUDIENCE: Capacity?
PROFESSOR: Capacity miss.
OK, so you have basically
cold and capacity
misses happening now.
OK?
AUDIENCE: One question.
[INAUDIBLE]
that you multiplied whenever
you're trying to load from
memory, is that like an
arbitrary number, or is that
the actual cost of going--
PROFESSOR: Every machine, you
can get this beautiful table.
I will go off what your
machines have.
We still have a number saying
this is your miss
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], this
is the thing--
I mean, so some of these things
you realize because of
all of the complexity.
It's not that nice and simple,
but this, I just pull out of
hat, and it's kind of normal.
So what do I do, now?
I am doing the mod, but I am
multiplying [i] by 16.
So now, I am accessing this
value, this value, this value,
this value in here.
I'm accessing this value, this
value, this value, this value.
One value in each cache line.
OK?
How much cache misses do you
think I'm going to get?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: 100 for every access
is basically beginning
a cache line, you're taking one
value and if I go back to
that value, I have already
filled up the cache.
So basically, I have first
access in the cache.
And what's your total
access time?
Anyone will take a guess?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yep, 100 times
x because I have no--
OK, so this is a
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
locality.
That was clear.
What kind of misses
am I getting now?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Now, I'm getting
conflict misses.
I get a cold miss at the
beginning, first time around,
and then every time I do
something, I'm getting
conflict miss because the thing
is, now, this N, I am
only accessing small
amount of data.
It doesn't fit in the cache, but
I'm not still getting any
kind of sharing, so I'm having
conflict misses.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] second
time, I guess I will
probably jump over this.
I just did OK, if I go random
access, what happens?
So let me jump over that.
Actually can do a calculation
to figure out how many,
probabilistically, how
much you might have
and stuff like that.
OK.
So now, if you look at what's
going on, when you have no
locality, you'd have
no locality.
That's a pretty obvious
statement.
And then if you have spatial
locality and no temporal
locality, we are
streaming data.
That means you are going through
the data, but you're
not getting back to it
fast enough, so I
have temporal locality.
So I stream through data, so
that means I go through data
in a streaming fashion.
OK?
So what we have is if working
set fits in cache, you have
InCache mode.
If working set is too big for
cache, you can get some
streaming mode and still get
some locality because we are
bringing the lines in here.
And you can do other things
like optimizers like
prefetching we'll get to.
And other issues
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
this last one, but to deal
with cache axises.
So if you have more than one
axis-- so here what I have is
too nice arrays.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] is 2 to the
power size array 2 to the 19
power arrays.
OK, so now what happens when
I put this in the cache?
Look what happens in here.
So what happens is this array
get mapped in this one.
This array get maps this
nicely in here.
So what happens is this line
can only be in this cache
line, and this line also
only can be in
this line of the cache.
Do you see what's
going on, now?
So if you do this one, basically
every time you
access something--
See, assume I'm accessing this
data item, so I'm doing A, B.
I access A, I get this line.
I access B, what happens?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So this
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] is gone.
It is gone.
Now, I am accessing the
next one in that
cache line we made.
AUDIENCE: How do you know
what cache line-- or how
[INAUDIBLE]
cache?
PROFESSOR: Normally, in language
like C, if people two
arrays next to each other, they
should be mapped next to
each other in memory.
And if you want to be more
adventurous, you can go to the
assembly and then see what
their locations is.
So if you put A, A next to each
other, you normally kind
of get it next to each other.
So what this one is this
is pretty bad.
I should have gotten at least
some spatial locality.
I'm getting nothing.
Do you see what's
going on here?
Do you know what's
Know why I'm not getting
any spatial locality?
Because I am bouncing.
When I access this one, this one
is gone even though I have
more data in the same cache
line, so I'm kind of bouncing
two cache lines because
of that.
What's a good solution
for this?
Back there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
A and B could be mapped to
the same cache line.
PROFESSOR: The thing A is
a nice 2 to the power.
A size is a multiple
of the cache size.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The size of A is a
multiple of the cache size.
So what happens is if you have
memory in here, you map
something like A, C here.
If this is a multiple of cache
line, so assume this is 32K
times some number, and you map
B here, and then this is
normally what happens in C.
You put all adjacent map
allocations next to each
other in memory.
Do you got A here, and
you start having B in
here, next to it.
OK, so what happens is now if
A starts to assume address,
we'll say 100, this is 100 plus
32K times N, basically.
And you do this mod 32K, this
mod 32K, this same number.
It maps into the same line.
OK, so I kind of gave
you the problem.
What can be the solution?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
allocate one line.
PROFESSOR: Yes, it's
called padding.
OK, so I have no locality in
here, let me go to the next
slide, what kind of misses?
I have cold and conflict.
What I can do is just
basically add a
little bit of padding.
I did 16 here.
Normally, you do a prime number
so it will not clash
with anything.
Add a little bit of padding at
the end of array, and that
means the next array
will not be
conflicted most of the time.
So a lot of times when you
declare things next to each
other, it's always good
to add a little bit of
a padding in between.
Normally, a smaller prime number
would be a good thing
to add a padding.
Now, I start getting back my
nice locality because the two
things are mapping the
two cache lines.
What type of locality
do I get here?
Anybody want to take any
guess what type of
locality I have here?
AUDIENCE: Question, sorry.
[INAUDIBLE]
you actually added
just an extra 16.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Why would that just
make the A and B [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Because what happens
is normally it doesn't
make A and B into leaving the
cache, but it makes A[0]
not exactly matching to B[0].
A[0]
will interleave with something
like B[16]
or something.
This thing might map into
the same place.
AUDIENCE: I mean, but
I [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes, normally
in a computation,
people do that, A[i]
equals B[i]
plus something.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK,
so [INAUDIBLE].
Like I understand what you're
saying, but I don't understand
how that [INAUDIBLE]
because they're both accessing
[i] at the same time.
Why would they [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So here's
the problem.
Assume I have [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
32K.
I'm assuming [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
OK, so first one is, we'll say,
you start with 100, 100
plus [i], and the other one
is 100 plus 32K plus [i].
OK, then you take a mod
32K, and this end up
being 100 plus [i]
with another 100 plus [i].
So this is basically
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
You still have one or one
element in the cache it's all
going to map into.
You see that?
But now, if I add 16 more to
this one, then this map into
116 plus [i].
AUDIENCE: I don't see that
reflected in the code.
You just [INAUDIBLE], so
how is B different
from A in your code?
PROFESSOR: Because
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] my S. I added
16 to S, so my A is a little
bit bigger, now.
AUDIENCE: But isn't B
also [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, B's
also bigger here.
I don't care.
B goes down here.
B, I add a little bit more to
the B. It doesn't matter.
I padded B, too.
So what that means
is the first A[i]
and B[i] are not in the
same cache line.
AUDIENCE: How do we allocate
A and B right
next to each other?
PROFESSOR: So normally in C, if
you declare something like
int A [100], int B [100], more
or less, they will be
allocated next to each other.
If you look at the assembly
listing, it'll say code
allocated next to each
other in memory.
Even in the stack, if you do
that, if you allocate things,
compiler has no incentive to
go and move things around.
AUDIENCE: This is only for
global and [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Global variable,
local variables.
AUDIENCE: Does any of it still
apply if you use malloc?
PROFESSOR: The thing
about malloc is--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It might do something
[UNINTELLIGIBLE],
but on the other hand, if it is
fitting on the same page,
it might also do something
like that, too.
So it depends on
how we do that.
At the beginning, if you keep
mallocing things, it might be
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
They might be a little bit off
because malloc put some
metadata with each status.
If you ask for [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
you're not
getting exactly 100.
You're getting a little
bit of a bigger size.
But you might have some
configuring to do, but after
some time, when you have done a
lot of [UNINTELLIGIBLE], we
have no idea where
it's going to go.
It's random.
Anymore questions?
OK, good, that is
a good question.
So what kind of locality
do I have here?
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
two lines, I am accessing each,
and I got 16 times 15
out of 16 hits.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: Spatial?
PROFESSOR: Spatial locality.
And of course, if you have
spatial locality, you get cold
misses, basically.
And I think [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
you get what
other type of misses?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
conflict here.
Basically, capacity.
Capacity miss, exactly.
So in order to avoid this, what
we have done is we make
cache-- instead of mapping into
one place before, and
what we said was we had
this memory, and
assume we have 32 sets.
And if you have a cache like
this, we make this entire map
into this one, and this
map into this one.
What people have done is instead
of doing that, what
you can make is make the cache,
instead of one big
block, two small blocks.
So what that means is this
can happen to this one.
My drawings are not
that great, but I
hope you get the picture.
This map into this one, so
what that means is each
reference here, so maps
here, and these
two basically conflicts.
But now with that
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
too, I can put this
one here or here.
I have two places to put the
value, basically, and that
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
OK, so that means if I access
something conflicting,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], you cannot
just two things.
Still, there are places in
the cache for them to go.
And one way to do people is
fully associative cache.
It can go anywhere, but that's
very hard to do in hardware,
but you can do some small
number of ways.
So in here, if you do two basic
associative cache, in
the first axis in here, even
though these are conflicted,
on can go to one
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] set, another
one can go to the other set.
OK, so two associative cache
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So total access time, again, I
have nice locality in here,
spatial locality, and I have
both cold and, I guess,
capacity misses.
But if you have two associative
cache, what's the
next problem?
How about if you have three
different things?
So we have two different
things like that.
OK, now that I only have two
associated [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
it doesn't work because, in
a [UNINTELLIGIBLE], I will
replace the last thing, and you
might still end up with
nothing in here because you are
replacing nothing, and the
next thing replaced
the other thing.
And basically after you
gave B, C, then you go
to A. A Is not there.
When you go to B, B is not
there, C is not there.
You kind of go back to the same
problem in here, and then
basically have to access
everything again.
There is some spatial locality
but cache can't use it.
Basically, you have
conflict misses.
OK, so you see that?
So associative is good because
normally people assume you
don't need that much
associativity, but it's limited.
So if you have too many things,
you might run into
this problem again.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You mean capacity?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]
capacity.
PROFESSOR: Less.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
elements in a cache before you
pick [INAUDIBLE] because it
looks as though the matrix
is is using half
the cache by itself.
PROFESSOR: Because it's
associated, you mean?
You have multiple there?
I mean, the thing is since it's
associated, no, because
you have enough room.
I mean, if you're going
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
everything, you have two
places to put the
name because it maps.
That's a good question.
So what happens is now, assume
this many things fit into the
cache before.
Now, cache has two banks, and
in each bank, only this many
things fit in, but the
next thing can go
to the other bank.
So if you go through
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], you have the
same behavior even if you
have associativity.
OK, you can go and--
because if the cache is the same
size, the size is what
matters for if you are going
through [UNINTELLIGIBLE] axis.
AUDIENCE: So far, [INAUDIBLE]
machines that we're working
on, do they have a fixed
kind of cache, or
can we decide like--
PROFESSOR: The fixed
kind of cache.
It's built into the hardware.
I will show the table
to say what type of
associativity is in there.
AUDIENCE: Is there not a
way to say [INAUDIBLE]
three-way associative?
Can you have something on top
of it so that it looks like
it's two-way associative
or something?
PROFESSOR: I mean, you can do
things like that in software,
but they're very expensive.
I mean, think about cache is
trying to fool the cache in
that direction cannot be that
easy because they are like
really hard-baked into hardware.
that's a good
question, but there are things
you can do, not exactly
modeling something, but kind of
putting offsets and stuff
like that so it doesn't get into
these kind of conflicts.
So yeah, I will answer
this thing.
Why don't you have more?
Because if you go back to
your [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
lectures.
Perhaps it might have
explanation in it's hardware
why it's much harder to build.
And if you have the
linked lists now--
so assume I have linked lists we
are going through in here.
And what's my [UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
Basically, depending on
allocation and using some
things, so best case is
everything is in cache, so I
have a small list.
And I go through again and
again, round and around my
list, everything's in cache
and [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
S. That's really great.
Next best is everything
is adjacent.
OK, everything might not be in
the cache, but everything at
least in adjacent memory.
So basically, first time I
allocate my malloc did a nice
thing for me, and at that time,
I basically get a nice
basic spatial locality since
my size is 16 in here.
So I get this much.
And the worst case is random.
Malloc puts it all
over the place.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
cache, does the thing behind it
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] in front
of it [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
also going to?
Do those both have a
spatial locality?
PROFESSOR: What happens is
normally, we assume 64 element
cache, so it's at that boundary,
so basically 2 to
the 8 boundaries is
what happens.
So what happens is cache line
begins at 0 address, 64
address here.
So if you get 63, that means
this value is not in the
cache, so you get
this cache line.
So the cache line
doesn't shift.
It's fixed chunks in here, so
that if you get address 0, you
get this one, and all
these things.
If you get something in the
middle, you'll get the left
and right [UNINTELLIGIBLE], but
if you get here, you only
get the right.
So this basically 0 and 64,
they are boundaries
[INAUDIBLE].
If you like 65, that's it.
But that said, if you're
accessing [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
that's this thing called
prefetcher that say you are
going through linear pattern,
and you might need that next,
and it'll bring this
up for you.
And what you find, I'll show
later, that in fact, the
machine you're using has a
really powerful prefetcher, so
it can hide a lot
of these things.
So we'll get to that.
So this is my total access
time in here.
Random case.
Random case is basically, every
time I access something,
it's not in the cache.
And then if you have a bigger
struct in here--
but assume I have this big
struct in here, but I am only
accessing one element of
this struct in here.
I do a lot.
I created this large struct,
and I am [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
things in the struct,
and I just basically
looking at my data.
Only one element.
What's the problem here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Exactly, so I bring
the entire cache line, but I'm
only using a little bit of it.
Because I bring all these things
into the cache, it
comes with axis and that,
but I'm only using data.
So basically, what happens is,
if everything in the cache, I
have access time S.
That's great.
That's not a problem,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
streaming.
Even though I'm getting spatial
locality, I only get
half of it because even though
I'm bringing the cache line,
only two have datas because
this is 32 bytes long.
It's in my cache.
Even though I am bringing all
this data, I only two of them
in the cache because rest of
this other data is kind of
hanging in there with me,
and so I don't get that.
And random, of course,
you have no locality.
So how can I basically
make this better?
How can I make this better?
OK, I just showed
it very fast.
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So instead, if I
ask you, I have this large
data structure, but most of
time, I'm only accessing a
small part of it, this is kind
of a little bit of a hack.
I mean, this is kind of going
against, I guess 6005 kind of
building, but this
actually works.
What you can do is, you can go
back and instead of doing
structs, what you can do
is you can do arrays
of each data item.
And now what happens is that I
am basically bringing these,
and then the data I am accessing
is basically right
now next to each other.
So you might have this very
large data structure
representing something you
have a lot of, then.
But most of the time, you're
only using few of them, so you
don't have to be structs
of arrays.
You might have couple of
different data structures.
One is the one that you access
regularly hopefully you get
them next to each other.
And the nice thing about arrays
is it guarantees things
are next to each other.
Of course, was managing
it is harder.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You can do both.
So that means instead of doing
the structs, you use arrays of
each field.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Instead of.
So instead of doing this one,
you just do this one.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
instead of being able
to pass stuff over.
Now you have to kind of be able
to know [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
so what that is where because
you cannot just pass the
struct [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No, you can't
pass the struct.
You basically have to pad the
index in here for this
structure, basically.
So you have to know something
in there.
So this is a lot messier, but
it can actually give you a
performance if you do this type
of access, so it's not
something you want everywhere.
That's why you still want to
use structures and nice
classes and stuff.
But this, if you're doing very
large data, but most of the
you're accessing only small
amount, this kind of
representation can help.
So I want to get a little bit
into matrix multiplying.
So what we're looking at is this
four by four matrix, and
you can represent it using
this representation.
But to make it clear, what I'm
going to do is I'm just going
to allocate this entire thing
as a single array, and I'm
going to do that
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] calculation
myself because if you go a
little bit down, you realize
this is allocated in a little
bit of a weird way.
And so this is what we call
row-major because all rows are
next to each other, and you
can access allocated
column-major.
Basically that means now A001,
instead of that, 1, 0 is next
to 0, 0, 1, 0, 2, 0.
And then basically saying same
thing, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
instead of saying 4i plus
j, it's just 4j plus i.
You can do both.
So this is my nice matrix
multiply function, because the
reason I did it this way, it's
just very clear how many axis
I'm going to use.
So if you look at C, let's look
at only the inner loop.
Most of the mapping matters
in the inner loop.
I go for k in 0 to size.
Only first axis on C is going to
miss because it's going up
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
same K, da-da-da-da-da, so
C is very nice in here.
Only get one miss in here.
You have a question?
OK.
A has a streaming pattern
because every time I update K,
I go to the next element,
next element, next
element, next element.
[INAUDIBLE].
What type of a pattern
do I have in B?
AUDIENCE: Looks like
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
I have jumping on memory.
I'm jumping one to another.
So if you look at that, I am
going through A like that, and
B, and going through C element
at a time, basically.
So if you look at doing this
in order to calculate one
element of A, [INAUDIBLE]
calculating these, what you
have to do is I am getting
B and C this way.
I'm going through row here
and column, and this row
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
fit into the cache line through
that because this is
the memory.
But C is just jumping all over
the memory, and I have no
locality in here.
So what can we do here?
What's the simplest
thing in here?
How do we get some locality
into the C?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So yeah, you're
coming, you're getting it.
That's the next thing that's
most important.
That's the more advanced
thing you can do.
We'll get there.
What was a simple thing
you can do for C?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
So here's the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
execution time, original, and
voila, when you transpose
that, you can actually get a
huge benefit in here because,
now, I get spatial locality
in both sides in here.
And so now when you're
transposed, I am going
through like this.
So now what I did was I am
giving this CPI, and what
happens is when you transpose,
I have a 5x
improvement in sync CPI.
That means instructions actually
not waiting, not
doing nothing.
I have a pretty good reduce
of cache misread.
because, now, I'm
actually going
through cache very nicely.
So the next thing we can
do is, what she just
pointed out, blocking.
So instead of matrix multiply,
just multiplying this matrix
at a time, you can multiply
submatrices and calculate
small submatrices.
And if you do that, the
submatrix can nicely fit in
the memory, so let
me show you that.
This is the blocking code.
Let me show you what
that means.
So what we are doing is you are
multiplying this matrix by
this matrix in there and
getting this matrix.
So what that means is, normally,
what you do is, to
get one element, you have to
multiply a row and a column.
Normally, we are calculating
a row of A at a time.
In order to get a row of A,
I had to get a row of B
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
entire C has to participate into
calculate A. So by the
time I have calculated 1024
elements, I have gone through
this many axises to new elements
basically because I
am getting B again and again,
but I had to go through the
entire C in here.
So if this much data is bigger
than the cache, I have no
locality in here.
But if, instead of calculating
a row, if I calculate a 32 by
32 block, which is again 1024
elements I am calculating.
If I do that, I need a block
here and a block here, and I
only type this much data.
OK, I'm getting the same amount
of output, but because
of reuse, I touch a lot
less inputting here.
And just by doing this
transformation, I can really
reduce the amount of data.
Basically, I can create a
smaller working set, go
through that much more, and
reduce the amount of cache
misses you get.
So by doing that, I basically go
out another 3x improvement
in my CPI, really brought down
my L1 cache misses, and
basically eliminated
L2 cache misses.
OK, so I got a really good
speed up in here.
So you can block multiple
levels, L1, L2, L3, because
every time you figure out the
workings and size, you block
so the data in that will be
safe in the cache in here.
And this is kind of nasty
to do by hand.
We'll see.
So the other interesting thing
is call stack locality.
So if you do something like fib
in here, traditional fib,
if you do fib(4), you calculate
a fib(4), fib(3),
fib(2), you kind of build
a stack, go up
back again in here.
So if you keep doing that,
the nice thing is you're
going up, but its--
Hopefully, one of these days,
I am going to hit the wrong
button, and--
What kind of locality do we have
if we are accessing data
like this in my call stack?
What kind of locality
do we have?
I mean, I access here, fib(4),
and I get back to fib(4) here.
So within each frame, I am
accessing data next to each
other, so I can have a little
bit of a spatial locality
because, each frame, all the
data is next to each other.
But across frames, normally,
I will have some temporal
because I will get back to
that data some time.
OK?
OK, before I summarize,
this one.
If you are reading a lot of
data, processing through stage
one, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
and producing [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
that means
you're reading a huge amount
of data through stage one,
save, save data again, do stage
two, you have really bad
cache locality.
One thing you can do is read a
small chunk, do all the stages
on that small chunk, save it,
and go to another chunk.
So instead of doing the entire
data, doing something
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
producing, you can do this
chunk-ifying, and by doing
that, you can get a
lot of locality.
So once you bring in data, you
like to do as many things as
possible to that data before
it gets out of the cache.
That's the entire thing about
locality, and you can
restructure code through that.
So if you look at that, what
we have done today, we have
looked at things like
associativity, cache lines,
cache sets in here, and how to
address and map to a cache, we
kind of did this thing, and we
look at [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
streamings versus InCache
versus no
locality type patterns.
And then when you look at data
structure transformation, we
look at how to basically replace
structured arrays and
split data structures to make
sure that you get a lot of
nice locality if you access a
certain amount of data, and
pack data to get smaller cache
footprints kind of things.
And we also look at computer
transformations, things like
transpose copying, compute copy,
outtype things you can
do, so you can actually get nice
locality, so you can do
both data and compute
transformations.
And [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
axises and [? re-cast ?]
calculation stages, so this
is kind of summary.
Next thing I want go is
look at what machines
you guys are using.
So this is the machines
we used last year.
These are quad cores, and it
had L1 cache, so these
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So this has 32 kilobyte
L1 cache, data cache
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
two caches in here for data and
instructions, each core,
and then the cache line size
is normally 64 bytes
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
And here, latency
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], you get
three cycles.
If not, you get 14 cycles to
go to to L2 in here if data
doesn't meet there.
And associated with this
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
So that was what we
did last year.
This year, we have a bigger
machine that has multiple
levels of caches.
So each core has L1 instruction
and data cache.
It's kind of the same, 32
kilobyte cache, four
nanosecond latency in here.
Eight, three and four
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], they kind of
reduced that, but they added a
256-kilobyte L2 cache in here,
and then a pretty large humongo
12-megabyte L3 cache in here.
The interesting thing is here,
this pretty fast access to
these ones.
If you miss in here, this is
about 2 and 1/2 times cost
from going from here to here.
From here to [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
about a five times cost, so
here to here is a
five times cost.
The interesting thing that
actually surprises a lot us
was here to here, it's cost
is not that different.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
So actually memory, even though
it's sitting out in
there, they have managed to get
it pretty cheap access.
Normally, my intuition say this
should be much higher
because you're going off-chip,
so this is the structure here.
It's a lot more complicated.
So here's something I
produced last year.
So what I did was I
ran this program.
And in these machines, there's a
way to turn off the prefetch
of the previous
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So when you've turned on the
prefetch and then you run,
what you are doing is I am
accessing data with a working
set, small working set, little
bit bigger working set.
So this is basically when you
consider working set size.
So you get a graph like this.
I am hitting my L1 cache, and
if it is more than that, I
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
L1 cache, I go to my L2 cache.
And if L2 misses, I have
to go to main memory.
Very traditional kind
of a graph in here.
Another a little bit of an
interesting thing, which is
instead of accessing
next item, I kind
of skipped in here.
So this trying to force how
to get conflict misses.
And so if you line up things
like this exactly, what
happens is you get these
conflict misses, and you get
this number.
So I have interesting
story to tell.
When I was a graduate student,
we were running this bunch of
benchmarks, and normally when
you run a benchmark, you try
it for an equal
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], stuff like that.
And we got this graph
like this.
I mean, we expect a graph
going like this.
OK, that how a benchmark
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Then at one point, by accident,
instead of typing an
equal 64-something, I typed an
equal 63, and suddenly, I got
a performance like this.
Wait a minute, what's
going on?
So in here, what I got
was not a line.
I got 16, 32, 64, 128,
nice graph like that.
And then I just did 63,
like down to here.
I'm like, geeze, that
can't be right.
And then I start looking
at 62, which is here.
61 is here.
So I realize if I enumerate
all those things, I got a
graph like this, basically.
Kind of something like this.
And the thing is, if I had never
tried the 63, I would
have basically thought my
performance was like
this, so far worse.
Never realized because it was
all having conflicts in memory
because I'm [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
2 to the power numbers.
So this is what happens if you
just look at 2 to the power
numbers, you'll think, yeah,
this is the performance you're
getting, without realizing
that, in fact, you
can get this far.
So this is good.
So I ran it on the
new machine.
The problem with our new machine
is there's no way to
turn off prefetching.
OK, so this is what
you're getting.
Everything, because I am
accessing this nice linear,
looks same.
This is exactly what
you want to happen.
What it's doing is, minute you
go to access, it realizes you
accessing linearly.
It start fetching, fetching,
fetching data in front you,
it's going to catch up.
It's not feeding you data, so
you're not going to have any
cache missed because you're
going through this nice,
linear pattern, and you just
basic end up with this
beautiful graph, which gives the
feeling your working set
could be, now, gigabytes long.
At this point, I am fitting into
the entire L3 cache, and
still look like this works
beautiful because this is what
you want for it to figure out.
So now I'm like, geeze,
this is great.
This means my cache works, it's
very nice, but I want to
show you guys what's going
on, so that doesn't help.
So I came up with
this program.
So this program, what I did was
I created a working set,
but I'm accessing randomly
within that working set.
I calculated this address.
This is my poor man's random
number generator, so basically
I'm adding number in here and
multiplying this, and then the
masking these to get the
right [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
so I get within that
set in here.
And then I just access
data, so I'm getting
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So I get a number like this,
and this jump up here, and
then I had this kind
of behavior.
This is a lot more
complicated.
I need to figure out what the
hell is going on in here, so I
said, OK, let's now look at
performance counters.
I look at L1 cache miss.
OK, up to 32K, I have
no cache misses.
Boom, cache misses jump up.
Perfect.
And I have this little bit of a
kink in here, this beautiful
describes because I have 32K
L1 cache, and until then, I
have no things, and then when
the cache start missing, I'm
jumping up.
Perfect.
I got that description here.
Then I look at my
L2 cache misses.
This is, I think, the L2 cache
in this machine might have a
little bit more complex
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
telling us because this
is not going like
here had jumping up.
That's a 256K [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
get.
Is this 256?
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
250 is [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
these things.
OK, so we have 32 256 2L
megabytes in here.
Even if you have 256 in here--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Hm?
AUDIENCE: Should it
be 256 or 32--
PROFESSOR: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
because everything's backed
up, it's hierarchy
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], so it's not
added to, it's not next to
each other, because at this
point, L1 is now useless.
It'll run everything is just
going to L2, so L2 is the one
who was serving it.
Come on.
So what happens in here, this
normally should start jumping
here, 256, but it start jumping
earlier, so there
might be some other interesting
thing going on here.
It might be interesting
to investigate.
So this is OK, so still
I am pretty close.
I realized this jump is
basically because of L2
happen, this jump in here.
L2 start missing.
Then I look at L3.
It's here.
What's happening here?
So this was a big mystery the
two of us were trying to debug
what one hour ago.
Not one hour.
Class is going.
Like two hours ago.
We was trying to figure out,
OK, wait a minute, this
doesn't make sense.
My performance is here.
L3 should be just basically a
nice flattening out here, and
just jumping.
It's not doing that, and we are
like what's going on here.
So then we were scratching our
heads, and we start looking.
I say, ha, there were other
things going on.
We looked at this thing
called TLB.
Let me tell you what TLB is.
What we realize is at this
point, we are [? seeing ?]
TLB misses.
How many people know
what a TLB is?
OK, good, so let me spend the
last couple of minutes
explaining what a TLB this,
and that kind of explain
what's going on in this graph.
So TLB means--
Normally, data is stored in
memory using real addresses.
That means there's a memory
size in here, there's an
address format, there's certain
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
And then the program for
it use virtual memory.
That means programs want to feel
like they have a lot more
memory than actual, physical
memory available.
So what happens is you have
virtual memory address, but
somebody has to map virtual
memory to physical memory.
So the way it work is there's
a thing called translation
lookaside buffer, TLB, that says
if you give this virtual
address, here's the right
physical address.
So of course you can't do it for
each address by address.
What you have is you have 4K
pages, so the address space is
broken down into 4K pages.
Each page will have an entry in
this TLB, saying if you get
this virtual address, here's
the right physical address.
So normally what happens is when
the operating system they
created this large table, for
every place in memory, you use
this table, and it loads
into memory.
Then the hardware will fetch
and cache some of those
entries in this TLB
cache in there.
So normally what happens is in
here, it caches 52L entries.
It can keep 52L entries
to 52L pages,
saying here's the mapping.
The problem with 52L pages is
in a 4K byte page size, 52L
pages can only hold two
megabytes of data.
If you're accessing more than
two megabytes of data, you
have to go more than 52L pages,
and at that point, that
mapping is not in the TLB, and
that means that you have to go
do a mapping translation.
The problem for this is
these 4K pages is a
very ancient artifact.
There's the new machines, you
can I ask for what we call
large-pages or super, but you
can ask for 2-megabyte or
4-megabyte pages.
If you ask for super-pages, then
of course, 52L entry's
good enough.
It can hold enough things not
to have TLB miss, at least
while you're in the cache.
But since Linux, without doing
anything, only asks for 4K
pages, before you run out of
your L3 cache, you run out of
the TLB table.
And it has to start fetching
and [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
data table, that means you had
to actually fetch the table
entries, and so you have
to do more fetchings.
So that is why this is even
running higher, because it's
trying to fetch this TLB entry
and stuff like that.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Is there a way to then
actually fiddle with the
TLB so that you have to fit
your pages rather than--
PROFESSOR: So in allocation, you
can ask for super-pages or
large-pages.
But in Linux, normally just ask
for 4K pages, so that the
operating systems haven't
kind of caught up
to the current hardware.
And this is was built
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
doesn't make sense TLB
to run out before
you run out the cache.
I mean, that's kind of
mismatch in here.
But it's built assuming you'll
get large-pages, but if you
don't, you're going to run
out of the TLB in there.
So this is why sometimes
performance engineering is
interesting, exciting, and
frustrating, because you
assume you know where the
hell this is going.
You assume this is going to go
here and that, and suddenly,
this miss shows up, and so we
have to scratch our heads.
And luckily, we found what's
going on, but we could have
spent hours or days trying to
figure out what's going on
here because this is one
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
say OK, let's try TLB,
and it worked.
That was really good, but I
have, many cases, spent days
trying to figure out why
something is going on because
performance is kind of
a [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
of everything.
There's no nice abstractions
and stuff like that.
If you think abstraction wise,
somewhere outside the
abstraction, that's
going to kill you.
So that is why it can be
interesting, because you have
to know everything.
And the fun thing is, once you
understand performance, you
basically understand end-to-end,
soup to nuts,
what's going on.
OK, with that encouraging
thought, let's see how you
guys do in the next part
of project two.